do you think
you are in part a sociopath
no
would you know it if you were yes how
does this work so what have you learned
from reading this book i had all these
interesting thoughts about all these
sort of questions and thoughts about it
because um
the book i'm reading now that i'm only
about a third of the way through she
talks about um
some of the things in the brain
structure that are particular to
sociopaths
and so then it makes you think well what
if that could be
tweaked in some way like could you
unsociopath a sociopath is it nature or
nurture like i suppose is the question i
think it's both
um i think it's genetic and then it's
like genes that are turned on
by
things like a particularly violent
childhood
or some sort of a dysfunction so i think
somebody could have the gene it's not
turned on and then
the sociopaths
have the gene and it's turned on
so so sociopath means that you're not
able to be empathetic or you're
generally not empathetic to the to the
suffering of others or to the emotions
of others i mean it's a hollowness so
it's like you don't have
um
just completely lacking the capacity i
mean it's tragic because they
wouldn't understand or feel love
but it's like a hollowness
and
and then
something also about the wiring and i
think also because of that hollowness
they're able to
incredibly quickly
look at others and identify their
insecurities and
buttons
and weak spots
so they're incredibly good at
manipulation is that because they're
just able to objectively observe the
situation i wonder probably in part but
there was some other explanation related
to the brain structure that i read
somewhere that made sense to me and i
won't like remember it because i don't
usually you're not andrew huberman no
reference i'll listen to it perfectly
yeah every single live from every book
or paper he's ever read yes right i
don't remember things in that way i try
to usually remember the conclusions
right so like i might remember that
he he might give a whole long
explanation about why it's good to do
this or to take this supplement
that's a bad habit i have sometimes i'll
order supplements and then by the time
they arrive i've forgotten why
i forgot why just take them all supposed
to samara thompson but the healthy
version i hope we get to talk about food
because i feel like
yes you have a brain that should be
fed only the best food
oh wow so we can talk about that later i
have a lot of philosophies about that
but certainly fluff is not
in the best what is best we'll
definitely talk about food um throughout
what is best
um
that makes me think of conan
and i just talked to oliver stone who i
didn't realize wrote conan the barbarian
uh do you know that in my head i i
pictured conan o'brien that's what
he's also saying
wait why
i love him but when you said that i was
like why did that make you think of
conan o'brien
yeah yeah i love him so much such a
brilliant human yeah
sociopathy sociopathy yeah so it's stuff
about the brain fine
but how do you know you're not a
sociopath would you know it
am i a sociopath how would i know it
how you know
well having listened to a lot
why wouldn't i be able to be good at
faking it it's not what well
there's the master and the cover of this
book
i don't think you would be doing the
work don't worry
you'd probably be running for office or
you know a trader on wall street or
one of the things about sociopaths is
they um
they kind of need like this stimulation
of risk and
danger
um
well
i need
okay sure more than average i like
okay
but wall street
there's a fakeness
like i don't like the fakeness of what
the game of it
yeah that's why i left
i didn't i just
it was a strange environment okay
so you're not you're not a quote
defective arrogant sociopath what does
defective even mean i know well i think
that somebody had just called me that
and i think that
you know it's easy for people to say
like don't read the comments but it's
hard
not to because then also you'd miss the
beautiful ones um or sometimes like you
have to go on there to to check a
private message and you just stuff
it's there people saying terrible things
so
um
i try to
people say you know don't pay attention
to the comments it's hard not to but i
try to
even with the documentary you try to
still kind of
see
to look
to look for the for the good ones for
the kind ones for the support there were
overwhelming kind comments and so that
that
helped and felt a lot better but
sometimes
um
sometimes the
the negative comments
or based on you know they're based on
false information so if somebody unders
if somebody knew everything that
happened
and then wanted to judge me or say
things like that's
somehow
at least that's all right but
um so you think people saying these
things based on
um
things that are totally false it's just
it's hard it's it's hard to
just let that go
um
but i know that people also say things
you know for their own
personal
reasons i had a fascinating exchange
with somebody who direct messaged me
and called me trash
um you responded i responded because it
was i
no it was amazing so okay i would do
this
wow it's sort of like a
i might be procrastinating or but
i would scroll through
because the private messages were
overwhelming and there's still just this
massive backlog that i'll never probably
get to read but the one that called you
trash as a pickup as an opener you're
like
this is interesting i just was in a mood
yeah and so i responded
and i wish i hadn't deleted it because i
i sort of deleted a bunch and then i was
like oh why did i delete that one
because i was curious what exactly i
said to him but i responded to him
um in a nice way
and then he responded back and then it
started this whole back and forth
conversation
um so he was kind quickly or no yes and
then also like wanted to get to know me
and lives in pennsylvania and was like
i'll come to you i'm like
do you realize if we you know if somehow
this just turned into like that would be
our how did you meet story well he
called me trash
online that's pretty good yeah he ended
up having such an insightful
comment
i just found it interesting and i think
first he said i never imagined you'd
reply which is you know it's like part
of the whole thing with social media
although this guy wasn't anonymous
um
was not anonymous no he had a i think he
had a private account but it's like his
name and his face was there and people
forget that you're a human being when
they message you exactly folks when you
message me i'm a human being
so
i told him that that was you know like
that that i was hurtful yeah and um and
i guess i wanted to understand more why
he said it and
it was surprisingly insightful but he
said something about again i wish i
hadn't deleted it that
he
um
he was like i guess i was just
angry because
um
like that guy
he said something like i guess i was
just angry because that guy got you and
i would have you know so it made me
think of the whole like sort of
in-cell jealousy
thing that can be very terrifying if
you're
female is that like if you reject a guy
they might turn around and be
violent or angry at you
and um so his
well to be fair there's a dormant anger
in probably all of us
i believe there's a capacity for cruelty
and anger and destruction all of us and
the whole struggle of life is
to uh emphasize the good stuff
yeah yeah so it's not just an insult
thing it's true for men and women both
yeah capable of cruelty that's that is
very true but this one guy so and then
you put on my therapist hat because we
we started what do we start with
um
i already forgot but the the
back to sociopath no
no just
you know maybe it's not the best idea to
answer the comments that start with
your trash i don't do it all the time it
just i happened upon that one and i was
just in a certain mood i was just in a
certain mood well let's let's and i like
their offline sort of yeah um
discuss this mood that you're in because
it might get you in trouble at some
point in your future
you